speaking of boy bands I had uh I had no
idea Shawn Mendes was a man condom yeah
dude I had no idea he was what the [ __ ]
yeah he was full-on [ __ ] boy Wow yep
he was like probably the most wholesome
one though the one that was actually
talented out of all oh the only one who
kept his shirt down in all the shower of
pictures yeah exactly yeah they're all I
don't get those well I think all nine of
them in like the hotel bathroom he
looked yeah let's get [ __ ] naked
right now and he's like I'm throwing
he's in the back with a guitar yeah he's
like oh yeah that's weird he's weird
that someone can be like a international
superstar right now yeah and like the
origin is magcon well I saw I was
reading an article about Shawn Mendes
and it was talking about the guy who
created man con he goes you know it all
started when someone introduced me to
their son they told me I like this big
fall in a social media and I thought
what if we created an experience around
these fans
it's basically boy bands without the
music I'm like so it's just little girls
wanting to [ __ ] little boys no boys yeah
essentially then you know it just is
sort of musically man I saw alright this
is a years ago but someone had tagged me
in a man compost and they were saying yo
dude what the [ __ ] is this cuz I did
that Twitter video like making fun of my
own okay so for a minute people would
send me funny man Casas and it was it
was a mad con event I don't know who the
dude was but a girl comes up and he like
kisses her like he like I was like a fan
meet-and-greet and there's like a line
of girls to meet him and she walks up
and he goes like it's like I guess he
remembered her that that was kind of
like the interaction it seemed like and
she wraps her arms around him and then
they just like kiss on the mouth
and then take a picture and then that
was it and I'm like
or say wait wait what how many times you
do this like in him it's a serious do
you just Mack knees girls damn that's
weird as [ __ ] weird as [ __ ] man and I
couldn't tell the dude was are we gonna
have to do that perk the VIP ticket one
kiss on the forehead is on the forehead
good to meet you thanks so much for
coming that's so bad
amen it's a it's part of the cult did
y'all if you have a baby they'll bring
that [ __ ] okay kiss yeah yeah yeah
that's the asterisk if you have a baby
we will kiss the forehead your baby
bring me bring me the baby
bring me the baby's 20 babies madcon is
such a weird uh I feel that it's not as
popular as it used to be I don't think
it still exists does it I don't know
yeah maybe just doesn't exist that's why
we don't hear about it it's just like
it's weird would somebody turn something
like that into something actually real
yeah like a business yeah like Shawn
Mendes are like [ __ ] Kardashian's like
like they were just reality TV show
people oh yeah and then they just
somehow I guess the whole thing came
from a sex tape didn't it or something I
guess their dad is yeah I guess yeah I
mean they're famous by other means but
I'm saying like Owen really knew like
that word for that yeah it's just not
like the standard that's the sex tape
that blew me yeah yeah but now they're
[ __ ] the realest [ __ ] ever
you know Kylie's almost a billionaire
just crazy man I was I was watching
Kelsey had the Kardashians on and I was
in the and I was in the living room by
the way I have a really embarrassing
story actually okay I have this I so she
had it on and I was like just like on
the couch dude on my phone or something
and Kim was talking about this argument
that she had with Kanye okay and it was
like it was like it was just I don't
know how that [ __ ] like wasn't on TMZ or
something like
she was describing how he got he blew up
at her I got super mad because she
didn't pick the right color band-aids
from the store oh man and he didn't want
to walk around with it with a teal
band-aid or something he wanted a skin
colored one no no or something like that
oh and she's detailing this argument and
I'm like this it sounds like you're
arguing with a either a three-year-old
or someone who's legitimately insane
which I mean he might be [ __ ] I don't
know but I was like why is this [ __ ] not
on Twitter or whatever like exposing
like that sad it was great it was like
really weird that's [ __ ] sad it's
like this weird moment in the show where
I'm like man it's if this is what the
show is all the time like I get why
people watch it I guess yeah weird
inside inside look I don't know I don't
yeah I don't know if it's made up we're
like through lately knee and Twitter
making some [ __ ] up and I know yeh like
has all these moments where he seems
sober and he put songs like I'm not
crazy as this is that and he seems like
it or seems that he is not sort of lost
his marbles but man when did you watch
him talking to trunk no I didn't not
kids to cringe I couldn't watch it I
just felt bad he seems completely manic
really he's just like the tangents he's
going on how fast he's talking Trump's
kind of looking at him thinking what
yeah he's not following what Kayne
saying and he kinda can't stick to a
point it's just all over the place and
only this man is so clearly not on his
rocker yeah and I don't know that maybe
his personality is too big that no one
can bolt him down well holy [ __ ] that
guy needs some help something Jesus it
it makes me feel bad because you Euston
or we used to know him as a really solid
artist great ideas and you know get that
do the right color band-aids yeah yeah
just so that being said Kim don't [ __ ]
it up next time you colossal [ __ ] you
colossal idiot that'd be great if he
actually said that yeah Kim you colossal
I can't because was more wrong you
[ __ ] idiot
[Music]
[Music]